[Music]
oh hey Dad I'm gonna be late
the hell you do with that book bag I
need to go to school no what you need is
to be out practicing with that tire now
the carnal lanes engine
[Music]
you gotta stop taking the tire off my
car and hanging it on trees
you gonna be second string all your lab
boy you think on earlene go to school
every day yeah he does he's in my AP bio
class I'll tell you what he told spiral
that tire Oh job you school myself
you missed you gonna see him practice
all day what no I I gotta go to school
make the throw
[Music]
go on go on
ap bio what you gonna be a botanist
running off to school like a little
coward I guess I'll get a car
[Music]
just give it to a straight doc it's bad
[Music]
it's real bad
how bad it's bad he's gonna miss mr.
playoffs no what about my legs doc will
I walk again Conor I don't think he
heard me son you're all missed play
office
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Jake Ramsey's gonna leave them football
boys to victory this Friday until that
number five proud you listening to the
whole pigskin the classics
wait a minute you're Jay crimson there's
this incredible QB one in my ride I mean
you probably know who I am 100 hotshot
Greenwood QB one has a 99 oh cool being
QB one changed my life coach Walker
convinced me to focus on football
Clinton messing around with veterinary
sciences now I got my side to us alone
uh who knows ma'am someday all this
could be years
hey yeah thanks for the ride
hey before you go I'm gonna give you
some
this for you Jake to make sure to give
me five stars
you